[موسيقى]
اقسم بالله العظيم
ان احافظ مخلصا على النظام الجمهوري
الديمقراطي الشعبي
وان احترم الدستور والقوانين
وان ارعى مصالح الشعب وسلامه الوطن
وان اعمل واناضل لتحقيق اهداف الامه
العربيه في الوحده والحريه والاشتراكيه
عقب وفاه حافظ الاسد في العاشر من حزيران
عام 2000 عقد برلمان النظام السوري
اجتماعا طارئا لتعديل الماده رقم 83 من
الدستور والتي تنص على ان سن الرئيس يجب
ان تكون اربعين سنه خلال بضع ثوان عدلت
الماده واصبحت تنص على ان سن رئيس
الجمهوريه في سوريا يمكن ان تكون اربعه
وثلاثين سنه تعديل تناسب حينها مع عمر
بشار نجل حافظ الاسد ووصف بالاسرع في
العالم
[تصفيق]
النشاه والانتماء ولد بشار حافظ الاسد يوم
الحادي عشر من ايلول عام
1965 في دمشق لاسره تنتمي الى الطائفه
العلويه والده حافظ وصل الى السلطه
بانقلاب عسكري عام 1970 تلقب بشار تعليمه
في مدارس دمشق ودرس الطب في جامعتها وفي
عام
1992 توجه الى بريطانيا ليختص في العيون
متزوج من اسماء الاخرس وله ثلاثه ابناء
حكم بالوراثه لم يكن بشار في دائره اهتمام
الاسد الاب فحافظ الاسد عمل جاهدا على
تهيئه باسل الشقيق الاكبر لبشار من اجل
خلافته لكن وفاه باسل عام
1994 بحادث سير وفق روايه النظام فتحت
الباب على مصراعيه امام بشار الذي عاد الى
سوريا فانضم الى صفوف الجيش السوري برتبه
نقيب حتى وصل الى رتبه عقيد ركن عام
ليتولى بعد وفاه والده قياده الجيش
بالكامل بعدما رفع الى رتبه فريق انتخب
بشار في عام
1994 رئيسا لمجلس اداره الجمعيه العلميه
السوريه للمعلوماتيه وهي التي تقود النشاط
المعلوماتي في سوريا كلف الاسد قبل توليه
السلطه باداره الملف اللبناني عام
1995 نظرا لتشابك العلاقات السوريه
اللبنانيه وفي عام
1998 لعب دورا بارزا في تنصيب ايميل لحود
رئيسا للبنان ونحن معكم ثائرون ندعم بقوه
اختياركم الحر للرفيق الدكتور بشار الاسد
نظرا لمزاياه قياديه وكونهم امتدادا
اخلاقيا وسياسيا وفكريا
لقائدنا العظيم الراحل حافظ الاسد بالنسبه
للاسد لم يكن الجيش وحده كفيلا باستلام
زمام الامور في سوريا في 27 من حزيران عام
2000 انتخب الاسد امينا قطريا لحزب البعث
العربي الاشتراكي الحزب الذي يحكم سوريا
منذ ستينيات القرن الماضي
وعود بالتطوير اضطر بشار الاسد في بدايه
توليه الحكم للعمل مع الطاقم الذي كان
يحيط بوالده طاقم تراس العديد من افراده
مؤسسات الدوله الاساسيه مثل الاجهزه
الامنيه والجيش لعقود طويله لكن شيئا
فشيئا تمكن الاسد من الاطاحه بهم مفضلا
مجموعه من مستشاريه المقربين
طرح بشار الاسد شعارات الشفافيه والتطوير
والتحديث في بدايه حكمه كقائد شاب يحمل
افكارا لتغيير الواقع في سوريا غير ان ذلك
لم يدم وما لبثت سياسات الاسد ان خضعت
للماثور والموروث وصار لعهده كما كان لعهد
ابيه معتقلون سياسيون وانتهاكات حقوقيه
ومعارضون في الداخل والخارج ان تطلعاتنا
لا يمكن ان تتحقق بشكل المطلوب
الا اذا تم التاكيد على دور المؤسسات في
حياتنا
احداث مفصليه
العلاقه بين سوريا مع الولايات المتحده
شهدت تازما بعد احداث الحادي عشر من ايلول
عام 2001 وبعد احتلال امريكا للعراق عام
2003 اتهمت حينها واشنطن نظام الاسد بدعم
الارهابيين الذين يتسللون عبر الحدود
السوريه الى العراق لمحاربه قواتها
اغتيال رئيس الوزراء اللبناني الاسبق رفيق
الحرير عام 2005 وما تبعه من انسحاب
القوات السوريه من الاراضي اللبنانيه تحت
ضغط دولي كبير شكل مفصلا حقيقيا في عهد
بشار الاسد حيث وجهت للاسد ونظامه اتهامات
بالمسؤوليه عن عمليه الاغتيال
مواجهه الثوره
عام 2011 انطلقت شراره الثوره في سوريا
وعمت الاحتجاجات الشعبيه جميع المحافظات
مطالبه بالحريه واسقاط النظام والاصلاح
السياسي عمل الاسد بدايه على تهدئه
الاحتجاجات باتخاذ عده اجراءات ابرزها
الغاء حاله الطوارئ المفروضه منذ عقود لكن
دون جدوى حيث اعتبرها الثوار انها لا تلبي
مطالبهم الضغوطات تستهدف دور سوريا
المقاوم لمخططات التقسيم الطائفي في
المنطقه حيث لا مقاومه ولا حقوق بل انهيار
واستسلام زج بشار الاسد بالجيش بكل قوته
لمواجهه الاحتجاجات الشعبيه والمظاهرات في
مختلف المحافظات السوريه فتحولت الثوره من
سلميه الى مسلحه
دخلت سوريا في اتون حرب ماساويه مدمره سقط
خلالها مئات الالوف من القتلى والجرحى
واعتقل عشرات الالاف وشرد الملايين استعان
الاسد لقمع الثوره بروسيا وايران كما جلب
عشرات الميليشيات الاجنبيه كحزب الله
اللبناني وحركه النجباء العراقيه وغيرها
وقوف اصدقائنا معنا وفي مقدمتهم روسيا
وايران وقفوا معنا سياسيا وعسكريا ووقفوا
معنا اقتصاديا منذ عام 2011 فاز بشار
الاسد بولايتين رئاسيتين على الرغم من
الاحداث الكارثيه التي شهدتها البلاد في
عهده
بعد اكثر من عقد على اندلاع الثوره تنتشر
على الاراضي السوريه قوات لدول اقليميه
وعالميه ابرزها روسيا وايران وتركيا
والولايات المتحده منذ اول يوم بالاستقلال
حتى هذه اللحظه من يصنع تاريخ هذا الوطن
هو القوات المسلحه وتحديدا الجيش